piste alors on va faire l'interview
référendum alors henri emmanuelli
vous allez répondre par oui ou par non
yes est ce que vous êtes pour le projet
de constitution européenne oui ou non
non est ce que vous êtes pour la turquie
dans la communauté européenne oui ou non
mais je suis entre les deux mais je
préfère dire oui et non est ce que vous
êtes pour françois hollande comme
candidat de la gauche en 2007
oui non mien est ce que vous êtes pour
une candidature ségolène royal à la
présidence oui non il veut me fâcher
avec tous les socialistes non si
j'achète cheminon superheavy est ce que
vous êtes pour le retour de lionel
jospin en 2007
willan en continu si j'aurais su ben je
serais venu à d'armure
est ce que vous êtes pour 25 la première
dame de france
oui non mu est ce que vous rêvez d'être
président non est ce que vous êtes pour
une loi contre l'homophobie contre oui
est ce que vous êtes pour la chute de
fidel castro
oui est ce que vous êtes pour la fin du
nucléaire en france
non est ce que vous êtes pour la ferme
célébrités 2
bon est ce que vous êtes pour le string
forum oui est ce que vous êtes pour le
vote par internet
oui est ce que vous êtes pour une
cigarette après manger oui non est ce
que vous êtes pour lyon champion de
france cette saison
oui non oui oui pourquoi pas est ce que
vous êtes pour que je vous tire les
sourcils pour voir si c'est des vrais
oui
merci en exercie branchements j'écoute
j'avais espéré mieux les sourcils mais
je m'en contenterai vous savez on va
peut-être vous arrivez mieux mais lille
mais